bueno gracias por la invitación les voy
a contar una historia interesante espero
que lograré entrar en el tiempo
bueno les voy a contar la historia de un
niño que no tuvo educación que creció
viendo la televisión y esa fue su
educación yo desde los 5 años ya había
mostrado alguna inquietud artística yo
bailaba cantaba me disfrazaba escribía
dibujaba tenía una necesidad
de expresión artística muy grande pero
yo aún no sabía lo que me iba a dedicar
y no sé qué sucedió en mi vida que
automáticamente yo decidí nutrirme de lo
que a mí me parecía importante tenía 5
años y era consciente de esto decidí no
ver televisión nacional porque la
televisión nacional me parecía que tenía
contenidos bajos eran vulgares los
chistes no me gustaban así que desde
niño aprendí a diferenciar de lo que era
producido en el perú y en el extranjero
gracias a dios yo vivir en los 80 y en
esa época la televisión peruana estaba
llena de programas enlatados que venían
de otro sitio y canal 7 sobre todo tenía
una programación increíble porque te
pasaban con medias americanas con medias
inglesas series fantásticas dibujos
animados de todo el mundo series
japonesas animaciones de transtel de
alemania teníamos tele match y yo podía
escoger de lo mejor de la televisión
mundial siempre evitando ver la
producción nacional que no entendía por
qué sucedía esto porque yo desde que
tengo 5 años me acostumbré a ver
televisión americana y aprendí a
comunicarme como americano aprendí a
pensar como un americano y eso chocaba
en la sociedad peruana desde que soy un
niño
nunca encontraba con quién jugar con
quién comunicarme porque los códigos
eran totalmente diferentes y siempre me
veían como el raro la oveja negra
de la familia el raro de la esquina el
que no funciona en el colegio siempre tú
eso pero es que yo tenía claro que yo
quería nutrirme de otras cosas un día
aprendí la televisión y un día apareció
gerardo manuel con su programa de disco
club y yo me quedé fascinado no
entendiendo qué es lo que estaba viendo
y lo que estaba viendo eran los primeros
videoclips que estaban sucediendo en la
historia esto antes de que saliera mtv y
me quedé fascinado porque mezclaban las
dos cosas que a mí me interesaban el
cine y la música y lo funcionaba en algo
decía qué es esto increíble y lo primero
que vi fue queen pink floyd y el vídeo
de la película fama fama es una película
que estaba de moda en el 80 y era lo
máximo una serie de sobre la vida de
unos estudiantes de una escuela en nueva
york que luchaban por triunfar y a mí me
parecía increíble esa situación el hecho
de luchar por una carrera
y vivir ese mundo de fantasía que uno
cree que es el espectáculo y luego salió
durán durán y salían en un yate con
supermodelos en locaciones extrañas
viviendo champagne y viviendo la vida
loca yo dije eso es lo que yo quiero yo
quiero vivir esa vida que increíble eran
los 80 recuerden que en ese momento
dinastía y dallas era lo que veía todo
el planeta el ser rico y famoso era lo
que aspiraba todo el mundo en los 80s no
estaba mal y yo crecí bajo esa sociedad
y decidí que quería hacer eso y la gente
como ustedes y como todos piensan que el
mundo el espectáculo son flashes y todo
es bonito y las alfombras rojas y los
artistas pero no es así y sobre todo no
es así aquí en latinoamérica y menos en
perú donde en ese momento salíamos del
gobierno militar y todo era terrorismo
entonces ese niño era yo
y a pesar de que había decidido vivir
esa vida les voy a contar todo lo tuve
que pasar para entender cómo es la vida
el primer recuerdo que yo tengo de mi
vida es una correa marrón or de una
estética horrorosa golpeándome sacándome
la mugre era mi padre a los 3 años que
sin razón me golpeaba por algo segundo
recuerdo en mi vida cuatro años
almorzando estaba comiendo a no quieres
comer garbanzos come
come no quieres comer la
quieres comer un toma
hasta que acabes la comida todos los
días de 12 a 4 de la tarde será mi
rutina nadie puede impedir que mi papá
me hiciera eso mi mamá mis tías y todos
nadie podía intervenir porque yo no le
caía también a ellos a mis 5 años para
que vean la situación yo ya había
planeado algo dentro de mi razonamiento
de niño cómo salir de esta cuestión
pensé haber grado pensé que grabando a
mi papá discutiendo con mi mamá y si yo
llevaba esa grabación a mi abuela iba a
poder llamarle la atención a su hijo y
diciéndole que se había portado mal yo
como niño creyendo que será la solución
para solucionar las cosas entre mis
padres y era difícil porque aprendí a
crearme a vivir en una burbuja creé un
mundo de ilusión y real una dimensión
paralela que estaba en mi cabeza y cada
vez que sucedían estas cosas yo las
llenaba de pensamientos positivos y me
prometí a mí mismo que en el futuro yo
no iba a dejar que esto pasara yo no iba
a dejar que yo no iba a tener una
familia violenta y un río a ser un mal
padre
yo no iba a ser un irresponsable cada
por cada cosa mala que pasara en mi
mundo paralelo yo iba determinando qué
es lo que no iba a pasar en el futuro el
colegio también fue difícil porque a
pesar de que yo era muy bueno al
principio las relaciones de la casa
hacían que mi rendimiento empezará a
bajar y me empezaron a volear porque yo
desde niño decía voy a trabajar en mtv
voy a ser director de vídeos musicales
voy a conocer a durán durán
voy a vivir esa vida de ricos y famosos
y todos mis amigos se burlaban de mí me
dicen tú estás loco de que vas a vivir
eso no existe para me escupían me pegaba
me arrinconaban enrique el loco de
si ese weon era una vida terrible
dicen que es lo peor cuando no te burle
a los del colegio si no te vulneran los
profesores la profesora de formación
laboral me humillaba todo el tiempo y
decía que yo no servía para el arte y
que jamás iba a lograr a desarrollarme
de eso y se burlaba adelante todos mis
compañeros igual que el director del
colegio una vez me humillo delante de
todo el colegio jalándome las patillas y
cuando yo le dije
voy a usarlo con mi padre me dijo tú no
le importas a tu padre
fíjate con quién quieres no le importas
a nadie
la vida era terrible y las discusiones
en mi casa llegaron a ser tan grandes
que mis padres se separaron y la cosa se
puso peor yo no sabía que no podíamos
sostenernos económicamente y entonces mi
padre dejó la casa y él se fue a vivir a
san isidro con unos tres carros que
tenía con la futura madrastra mientras
nosotros nos habíamos quedado
abandonados en una casa cinta rasguear
sin puertas ni ventanas y nuestro
cuidante era un perro dóberman no había
vivíamos en un sitio donde la
urbanización no había nadie a kilómetros
a la redonda porque no habían construido
todavía nada y en surco y la vida era
viviera llegar del colegio ser goleado
llegar a mi casa calentar la comida
cuidar a mis hermanos esperar hasta que
mi mamá llegar a las 12 de la noche yo
preocupadísimo que le estará pasando a
mi mamá y en mi dentro de mi psicología
está pensaba que estará siendo mi mamá
para conseguir dinero yo me torturaba
con todas esas cosas las cosas se
pusieron peor porque como yo era
asmático para colmo mezclaba
400 inyecciones acá 400 inyecciones acá
desde que tengo tres años para
sobrevivir así que me mandaron a
estudiar el equipo y yo sorpresa me
mandaron a vivir con mi papá no había
forma de escapar de esa situación la
situación con mi padre era tan difícil y
tan jodida que él llegó a un casi un día
ahogarme
en una discusión botón mil puertas y
solo les voy a contar ustedes creen que
el papá de los migueles una basura
el papel en miguel es un santo al lado
de mi viejo cuando yo tenía 16 años le
pedí un par de zapatillas puma para
encajar simplemente lo ustedes saben
cómo son los colegios como toda la gente
te juzga por las zapatillas la ropa que
tienes yo a veces no tenía ropa que
ponerme tenía que cruzar los zapatos y
esconder que mis zapatillas estaban
rotas no podía asistir a ninguna reunión
porque no estaba a la altura de los
compañeros del colegio le pedí un par de
zapatillas por el día de mi cumpleaños y
él me hizo creer todo un mes que me lo
iba a comprar saben qué pasó cuando
llegó el día de mi cumpleaños no me
compro las zapatillas y me dijo no te
las voy a comprar para darte una lección
para que te des cuenta que las cosas las
tienes que conseguir tú mismo yo le dije
que sí pero si me has prometido todo el
mes así es le dije entonces le dije no
me parece justo le dije porque todas las
cosas que tenemos las ha comprado mi
mamá y tú nunca nos compran nada saben
que hizo mi correteó por toda la casa
tuve que encerrarme en mi cuarto y qué
pasó
boto la puerta del cuarto
y me empezó a golpear hasta hasta que yo
no podía más y cuando no pude más agarro
a la radio que yo tenía el costado y la
destrozó y la rompió en el piso y dijo
la música la música es lo único que te
interesa lo único que has sacado de tu
madre y me dijo para que no te escapes y
asegurarme de que aprendas la elección
empezó a sacar las tablas de la cama
esas donde tú pones el colchón y queso
merecidísimas y me empezó a golpear las
piernas hasta que se aseguró que yo no
pudiese caminar
nadie me auxiliar en la casa y cuando él
no pudo más y yo ya no tenía aliento
para meter un grito más me metí un clavo
acá para asegurarse que yo no pudiera
caminar al día siguiente me mandó al
colegio porque yo no podía faltar al
colegio según él y mientras mis
compañeros me cantaban happy birthday to
you yo tenía que estar para tratando de
pararme y poder sostenerme en pie
tragándome todo el dolor interno de
saber que me estaban sacando la mugre mi
casa
después de ese día para ser la historia
más corta me tuve que ir de mi casa y me
escapé tenía 15 años y empecé a vivir en
las casas de mis amigos y empecé a vivir
errante mente tratando de sobrevivir
hasta que llegué a la casa de una tía
que me mantuvo por dos años ahí
mi vida al principio fue terrible y josh
aún a pesar de eso seguía estudiando
informándome mirando vídeos
coleccionando los escuchando la radio
comprando revistas informando menor
internet era la única manera de aprender
la carrera que yo quería tener yo hacía
cualquier cosa por por seguir y
nutriéndome de esto y yo empecé a
trabajar desde muy pequeño de los 11 a
los 17 años
yo hice la vida que todo el mundo hace
de los 25 a los 35 vivía en arequipa
vivir lima y no era ni limeño ni
arequipeño era una confusión terrible
porque en ningún de los sitios se
encajaba en los veranos y las vacaciones
de medio año me dio a trabajar con mi
mamá y todo el sueldo que yo ganaba era
recibir a mi chica y me iba a la tienda
de discos a comprarme discos y mi
psicología era lo casa y yo decía podía
de repente estar el disco es for dinner
yo quería comprarme el disco the phone y
ver pero salió el disco de milk y salió
el disco de la banda azul salió el disco
de duro y yo me los compraba a pesar de
que podía estar comprando música
americana y decía si yo compro todos
estos discos nacionales y apoyo al s
nacional esto va a surgir y algún día
ellos me van a apoyar a mí eso es lo que
yo alucinaba en niño a los 19 años me
enamoré locamente de una persona el
primer amor fuerte que tuve con una
chica y terminó sacando me la vuelta con
mi mejor amigo lo cual me separó de mis
amigos y me volvía alcohólico
tenía una caja de gato negro de vino
todos los días más un pisco hasta
sentarme en el piano y tocar borracho un
hombre solo de julio iglesias
lo hacía para deprimir medias auto
destruirme y yo no tenía la idea de que
yo desde que era un niño sufría algo que
se llama depresión y que en este país
nadie le da la importancia de lo que es
a los después de todas estas
circunstancias llegué a ingresar a un
instituto de comunicaciones donde
también fui mal visto porque yo en vez
de estar en la cafetería drogándome
saliendo a fiestas perdiendo el tiempo
lo único que hacía era practicar
practicar practicar practicar porque yo
quería esa carrera quería ser un artista
quería tener vivaldi quería hacer los
vídeos musicales de mi banda y me sacaba
la mugre mientras que todos los alumnos
decían quién te crees que eres que por
qué haces esto que no vas a llegar a
ningún sitio terminé el instituto y me
quedé sin piso
yo no tengo conexiones mi familia no
tiene conexiones acerca de la de la
televisión la música no sabía qué hacer
los primeros cinco años de mi carrera no
tenía ni un cliente coleccionaba de uno
en uno en uno hasta que pudiera hacer
algo los primeros trabajos salta
es que tuve todos mis amigos me
engañaron la primer mi primer trabajo
que fue institucional una chica me robó
20 mil dólares la segunda vez que tuvo
un proyecto de televisión mi mejor amigo
me metió un puñal en la espalda y se
llevó un proyecto de 50 mil le presten
la cámara que con tanto esfuerzo me
compré un amigo se la robaron nunca me
la devolvió ha hecho dos películas hasta
el momento y hasta ahora no me paga mi
cámara
todo estaba en contra y en uno y cuando
ya había terminado de ver todas las
posibilidades me pasó lo peor entendí
que ese mundo que yo quería no existía
en perú en perú no existen las disqueras
no existen los fallos que te van a
adelantar un millón de dólares por tus
ideas y te van a pagar los vídeos las
giras yo quería ser pink floyd y no
había ni siquiera un local donde pudiera
entrar una pared no iba a pasar nunca me
frustré terriblemente tenía 27 años y
entra el club de los 27 porque en ese
momento decidí suicidarme pero antes de
suicidarme me cuadre con el de arriba y
le dije por qué
porque me has hecho pasar esta horrible
vida no tengo un solo recuerdo bueno
todo ha sido mal mal golpe golpe golpe
basta basta por favor dime por qué estoy
acá
las cosas van a cambiar desde ahora le
dije quiero esto esto esto esto esto y
así a zsa zsa zsa zsa zsa si no hago
esta vaina porque realmente estoy harto
y si tu me das eso yo me comprometo a
hacer una cruzada no seré el artista que
quiero hacer pero voy a cambiar el medio
de los vídeos
soy el voy a ser el primer director
profesional de este país y cambiar este
medio y cuando lo logre cambiar quizás
algún día cumpla mi misión entonces
regresar y grabar un disco o seré el
artista que quiero hacer y a partir de
ese momento mi vida se dio la vuelta
como ya dijo marc pasaron cosas muy
raras mi primer vídeo fue número uno en
mtv dos semanas la tercera semana era
otro vídeo mío número uno en tv y la
siguiente semana era otro y otro y otro
y otro y era una cosa irreal llegué a
tener 40 número unos en canales
internacionales
he recibido reconocimientos de todo el
mundo hasta del congreso de eeuu por ser
un role model para mi sociedad y porque
mi trabajo eleva la calidad de las cosas
de este país entre un proceso de trabajo
workaholic que ustedes no se imaginan
trabajaba siete días a la semana no
tenía vacaciones y llegó un momento que
era tan popular y tan poderoso que yo
decidía cuando salían los sigue él
cambió el nombre de las canciones así
absolutamente lo que quería y si vivir
la vida de rockstar viajaba a fama
amigos excesos de todo y una vez más me
di cuenta que esa no era la vida que yo
quería donde habían quedado mis sueños
donde habían quedado las cosas que yo
quería así que algún momento dije basta
se acabó despedí a todos era la empresa
me compré un boleto y me fui a nueva
york- solo sin conocer a nadie y lo que
hice a partir de ese momento ya llevo
cuatro años en eso es levantarme todos
los días simplemente a cumplir mis
sueños e ir a la locación está la cual
no será el artista tal y efectivamente
todo lo que dije a mis compañeros se
cumplió conocí a durán durán trabajar en
tv cuando se debe a david lynch a night
rogers a pool abdul empecé a cumplir
cada pequeño sueño que yo quería
entonces ya se me acabe el tiempo el
mensaje final señores si yo pude si un
peruano solo pudo con tantos baches en
su vida transformar su pequeña carrera y
lograr hacer de esto una pequeña
industria que hoy día es súper rentable
para mí y que le permite a muchos
muchachos seguir esta carrera de
dirección de vídeos musicales que antes
no se pensaba entonces cualquiera puede
y si cada peruano hiciéramos simplemente
lo mejor en nuestra área de trabajo el
mundo cambiaría
seríamos otra cosa el poder de la
determinación de lo que quieren en su
vida lo tienen ustedes y son ustedes
quien pueden cambiar mi interés a la
edad que tenga no interesa la condición
social no interesa la raza lo que
intenta lo que interesa es el poder de
la determinación que ustedes quieren
hacer ese chico de la burbuja sigo
haciendo yo y hoy día continuó viviendo
en mi burbuja más grande más cómoda y a
mi medida pero sigo aún viviendo una
realidad yo no vivo como ustedes yo vivo
en un mundo paralelo y mi vida es una
película que yo todos los decir todos
los días decidido que sea un éxito para
cerrar señores simplemente les digo que
que vida a partir de hoy día ustedes
quieren vivir gracias
[Aplausos]